you
so do you know what time it is it's
already noon hurry up and get up you
have a meeting with Arden Cho today come
on bow David I did not say that do not
mess this up again like you do a parent
hi my name is Arden and I currently live
in Los Angeles I'm supposed to be
meeting David today to discuss some
business ventures am ia fan of Arden Cho
a scale of one to ten let's you say I'm
about a four mil you don't say that that
doesn't make sense David yes it does I
think this meeting could be the start of
a great business relationship this is
the worst meeting I've ever had
when I'm around a relatively attractive
girl a certain life might come out and I
think she might have been put off by
David hi so good to finally meet you
okay should we go inside I think we get
the hazing a copy what about you David
Chuck y'all okay you can do this 30 more
minutes so after we got past the whole
nervous laugh thing the conversation
picked up kinda so honey um you know I
actually have a lot in common
really like what
you have breasts I have press
okay hmm
that wasn't even the worst of it I mean
I literally almost ran into him his face
was like right there yeah not to mention
a staring thing yeah I know I know he
seems like a really sweet guy but
they're seriously something really off
about him
look I gotta go I'll seen a little bit
after coffee David heard I was going to
karaoke with some friends and he
insisted on coming when I heard karaoke
I was like a light bulb you know I'm
saying
Arden um I want to thank you for being
the best date ever
and let dedicate this song to you what
can I say my love is like quicksand the
more you fight it the worse it gets you
know say ah I never knew a man could
sing in falsetto for an hour straight
without an instrumental track you got
curly here what's up what don't nee dude
how she sings it's cool
thank God for karaoke cuz I'm pretty
sure I saved the date with that when you
all say Shh
you know what I don't think we'll be
working together ever
Arden so has a nice ring to it doesn't